Roger stone is on the phone Roger how
are we doing good morning gentlemen hi
Roger how are you I'm about to go from
being one of the greatest interviews of
all time to being one of the most boring
well we are okay we understand what you
can say in Canton we don't want you to
we don't want you to get in trouble
quite a bit you can't talk about how
Roger well how about this can we talk
about can we talk about rich Voss and
how we all agree that he was an ass can
we discussed that yes yeah
now here's what I can't believe about
Roger stone you know I kind of expected
to pick up the phone just now and hear
like hey guys yeah it's been tough but
Roger stone you sound as much like Roger
stone as you have ever sounded when we
talk you don't sound broken you don't
sound beaten you sound downright peppy
it's pretty it's almost inspiring well
look I have pled not guilty I refuse to
change my plea I'm anxious to get to
trial trial won't be till November
because it's a very complicated case I'm
highly confident that I can win at trial
and be vindicated because I know the
truth of what I did and did not do
beyond that you know other than asking
people to go to still in defense fun
calm to help me raise the two million
smackers I need for lawyers oh god they
really are you want a good one yeah I
can't discuss it but I'm pretty
resilient I'm pretty determined to clear
my name and let me ask you to obviously
overnight you're a lunch partner was
arrested so were you shocked that it's
not a young Julian Assange yeah I see
were you shocked I mean obviously you
didn't know it was coming or did you
think they were going to do that soon
anyway well there was a lot of
speculation over the last 72 hours that
this was about to happen and in a
strange way
he was in jail anyway because the
Ecuadorian embassy I was only outside of
it but it's tiny its dank no phone no
internet
he did have Pamela Anderson coming in to
see him once a week not too shabby
no but you know he's going to be here
and of course that that he'll be
available to the government for
testimony beyond that I can't speculate
about the implications how did he get
three rooms in that and then see he's
they said he got a WikiLeaks office he
got two offices a bedroom and half the
kitchen how did he get all that space in
that embassy well I think and by the way
I think the embassy shares space with
several other countries that small Wow
it's that small so but that's who would
give him asylum and there you have it
man and there was nothing they could
there was nothing they can do so you
talked to the president I have not I
have not talked one now in almost two
years I think largely because his
lawyers have suggested that we not speak
and my lawyers agree so we are not in
touch
do you miss talking to him yeah I really
do I mean we're you know I've known him
for 40 years we're very good friends you
know I don't agree with everything he
does
I agree with a lot of what he does
sometimes they would do things
differently but he was at my wedding
when I got married
I was at the wedding for four he and
Melania and Yvonne he and a Marla
pardoning and I was just awaking
tree-removal both of his parents very
friendly with his sister who's a federal
judge who I hope to get on the bench so
yeah do I do miss what what do you think
it would take for him because the press
really they did you just kill him for
every single thing you do what do you
think it would take for him to get a
friendly story in the New York Times or
The Washington Post that is when I tell
freezing yeah not gonna happen the New
York Times is off the rails I mean I'm
I've read the New York Times for 30
years in and it's my favorite newspaper
but on the morning of my arrest I read a
front page profile never mention that I
work for Ronald Reagan never mentioned
that I worked for it freedom
American presidents never mention that I
like to Tom Kane governor New Jersey or
many origami or Times bestselling author
never mentions any of these things I'm a
self-admitted dirty trickster well I did
some research
I have never described myself that well
boy heard myself described dirty
trickster no place have I ever said that
that's what I am what I've said is other
people have called me that and I guess
I'm stuck with it to their credit the LA
Times printed a correction last week
when I complain but in every story you
say you will see that I am Roger stone
self-described dirty trickster even
though I never said that I don't even
know if that hurts you Roger because
like everyone knows you're in politics
so everybody looks at politics like this
is kind of what they do so you're almost
a self-described dirty trickster almost
seemed like yeah yeah he's admitting
what all of them do it doesn't hurt
Roger right but it does hurt the
credibility of the newspapers that are
sitting there saying this is self
administrative [ __ ] of course I'm
saying for him though it's some of that
thing I think Rogers just trying to uh
just trying to make the papers look
foolish yeah I think he likes that I
don't think he's wrong yeah times is
delusional I mean they're completely
delusional they had this whole section
on the Russian collusion the whole
section of the newspaper I had my
research guys go through it we found a
hundred and thirty seven straight
factual errors written by a guy named
Mike Schmidt just total BS and even
their editorial page now won't come off
it despite the fact that the special
counsel has issued his report Roger are
you nervous about everything that's
going on right now that we won't talk
about the worst part of this is being
broke I mean you understand since the
last time I have been on your show I've
lost my home my insurance a lot little
savings I had my ability to make a
living because people pay me to and talk
and of course the things they want me to
write and talk about are the very things
I'm not allowed to talk in right at all
it's uh in the in the blink of an eye
you can lose everything how did you
you lose your whole eye you're home well
because I'd have to pay everything I
have to lawyers and I could no longer
pay the rent in the property that I was
in I moved from a nine bedroom house to
a one-bedroom apartment had to do the
move myself with my life renting a truck
on the last day of the move in a kind of
a freak accident the truck slips out of
gear and rolls over my wife's ankle
breaking it if I speak to you now I'm
headed down to the car pound in Fort
Lauderdale because I just got my car
impounded for parking tickets I didn't
even know I had it's one of those days
we're not winning right now say I'm
sorry
we're not exactly winning right now well
look I'm back in the gym I've been I've
been running five miles every day every
day am eating clean I'm in training so
and of course I spend most of my time
reviewing documents preparing for trial
now you have this impending thing which
I guess is gonna be on November don't
you want to just kind of get it over
with
or are you happy to have November to
wait until well part of me says I like
it to be tomorrow of course but the
preparation is enormous this is not a
secret that government announced that
they dumped four terabytes of evidence
on discovery let me put that in somehow
back there if it was paper it'd be seven
hundred and fifty million pages if you
stacked it up we would be the Washington
Monument times two oh my god so that's
an enormous amount of of stuff to go
through to prepare for trial I have four
lawyers it will read a hundred and fifty
pages a day we still wouldn't be ready
theoretically by
so wait a minute then do they do this do
they bury you in paperwork because
they're hiding the little few things
they might think they have like they
might not have much so what they do is
they'll give you ten thousand pages to
go through because there's three pages
that they
hinge their case on I didn't say that
okay you did okay get up what you're
putting down but that's what I'm
wondering first thing that occurred to
me that that's probably what's going
down
are you in paperwork yeah there's five
sheets of paper in that four terabytes
that are really really really important
find the five see you may know that you
have to pay their lawyers four terabytes
is roughly twice as much information as
there is currently in the Library of
Congress probably not going to use all
of it in the case so they're putting
full reports in there whether it might
be one line referencing you maybe
there's a report that was 600 pages
one-line references you they put the
whole [ __ ] report in there well I
couldn't speculate is Alex Jones helping
you out actually I'm kind of
disappointed in Alex huh he is not
selling the iconic Roger stone did
nothing wrong t-shirts which is you know
been a mainstay of my fundraising by the
way you can get the MIT 1776 back shop
why is he selling them I was assured I
was arrested in and he's not selling
them I've expected a nice contribution
to my Legal Defense Fund I have not
received one I'm a little disappointed
what would you consider a nice
contribution I saw about a week ago he
said that his testimony or his comments
on Sandy Hook something by the way I've
never spoken about at all or written
about was caused by psychosis he did say
that yep and then Saturday I saw a video
in which he said posses of men dressed
as clowns are going around abducting
children for sexual abuse
I hope he's alright I don't know so
you're a little upset that Rogers sir I
mean that allege that Alex Jones is not
helping you out I mean you did Alex
Jones a show for a long time pretty
loyally you are no legal stuff going on
too though he does have you I am
grateful for Alex Jones for giving me a
platform he is a friend of mine I like
the guy I like hanging out with him I do
not agree with everything he says I
agree with some of the things you can
he probably doesn't agree with
everything I say but you know a check
would be nice have you reached out to
him and said hey it's very very
successful and very very profitable and
hopefully he'll he'll throw a few
samolians my way now way to consider a
good would you consider a nice donation
of samolians 25 large would make me
happy it would be good have you told him
hey Roger chunk it be chump change for
him he has a very very successful
operation have you told her hey Alec
Simon's a brilliant brilliant model I
mean he is simulcast on 200 plus radio
stations the same time he's got a high
quality video presentation that
simulcast and he's uh you know and he
has no sponsors because he's his own
sponsor he sells his own products and
they sell briskly by the way I've used a
lot of a lot of more very good have you
told him hey Alex I'd really like about
$25,000 please well I'm not gonna get
into our personal conversations back of
course
have you gone have you gone on Joe Rogan
show I thought he was entertaining and
he's always entertaining no have you
gone on Joe show
I have not although I would like to
there's not that much you talk about at
this point unfortunately well I'd say
one big thing we could talk about and
that's the fact that I'm a strong
supporter of a legalization of marijuana
and here in Florida the new Republican
governor has legalized medicinal
marijuana and finally fixed a flaw in
the state law which said that you
couldn't smoke it and his popularity has
really taken off is there a lesson in
here for Donald Trump who is the friends
that have stuck by you Roger
I'm sorry a truck was driving by you'll
have to say who are the friends Sam
wants to know who the friends are that
stuck by you
well of course Kristin Davis the
Manhattan Adam a great pal of mine
this is the thing about adversity you
find out who your real friends are and
at this point 38,000 people have given
to stone Defense Fund calm for which I
am exceedingly grateful you forget us
we're good friends
huh well I'm looking for your checks too
but we won't get into that we don't make
as much money as you think we do we
don't make Alex Jones money yeah
unfortunately we're not selling our own
products I can tell that by the way you
dress that's right that's right I mean
Roger first Roger I have to I have to
confess something we were just in the
studio we were talking to you and we we
feel sympathy for you and everything but
I don't know if you just heard the noise
on the other end of the phone just in
case you did and thought it was
interference Jim I well then then they
know that I am NOT violating the judge's
orders and not discussing anything we're
not allowed to talk about Jim Jim
flatulate at a moment ago I couldn't
help it I ate eggs he flagellated and
he's been very flatulent this morning
and I'd like to apologize to you just in
case you heard flatulence while you were
trying to talk about all kind of the
hard to importance not having so now
wait a minute
ah in a moment I'll be out of this area
and able to hear you a little better but
so far I haven't heard anything an
associate oh god he did I will I heard
it he did flatulate yes I did how hard
is it for you not to talk about anything
you're not allowed to talk about well
there's plenty to talk about like the
2020 race and the the who yellow and
Gore Biden of Joe Biden for example you
like Joe Biden well I think Trump would
beat him like a drum I mean the guys are
like he's a physical and intellectual
lightweight can't see himself he
actually thinks he's important he's a
pompous blowhard who Trumper Biden Biden
oh and he can't seem to keep his hands
off of other people's children no oh
that's not a right-wing conspiracy
theory there are hundreds of pictures
and thousands of feet of video footage
of him inappropriately touching children
you can see their income
boy you can see their parents are
uncomfortable that's just weird
but do you think is on these touching
kids inappropriately she's just being
too affectionate like is that is it
sexual
yeah I don't know sexual I don't think
so it's just I look either way you look
at it whether it's women or children
because he's got the same propensity
it's creepy it is creepy I don't think
it's sexual but I do think it's creepy
actually there's footage where one u.s.
senator slaps his hand away from this
from his granddaughter because Joe's
getting a little too handsy so you think
the a real hiccup in Joe Biden's
potential run for presidency could be
that his opponents President Trump for
example may bring up the fact that
there's lots and lots of video of him
uncomfortably touching children and
women it's already being brought up you
know I have more serious problem
nobody's been a more zealous drug
warrior than he has already is more
responsible for locking up poor people
and black people for the first time
nonviolent offense of possession of
small amounts of marijuana then Joe
Biden our prisons are clogged with poor
people and black people who are subject
to far harsher sentences than rich white
guys get who get caught with cocaine now
did you ever see the photo of Biden with
the two ice cream cones and the
sunglasses he just looks cool I did not
okay he doesn't look cool in that photo
hey let me ask you Roger you're friends
with the president what do you think if
he could have the press give him credit
for one thing knowing that they're never
gonna be all on board if there's one
thing he get credit for what do you
think he would want to enter credit him
for the the economy I mean we have four
point nine million new jobs
we have 650,000 new manufacturing jobs
unemployment is at the lowest point in
American history african-american and
Hispanic unemployment at the lowest
point since they began keeping those
statistics it's impressive man I was at
the airport yesterday it took 35 minutes
to get through a TSA PreCheck line you
know what that tells me a lot of people
buying air
tickets the economy is goes right and I
think that's what he deserves the most
credit for 35 minutes you through pre
shake it was a I was in a fury if it's
any I also outraged well Roger I let's
promote this properly
it's called stone Defense Fund is at it
on stone Defense Fund dot-com Rogers an
upcoming trial and the stone cold
haven't heard about that what's that the
trial I hadn't heard about that yeah it
has happened all the stone cold Defense
Fund fundraiser it's at the Paper Moon
gentlemen's club oh yeah in Richmond
Virginia this is Saturday May the fourth
at eight o'clock
I'm guessing Kristin Davis will be with
you Roger have you thought since the big
event it's happening May 4th at 8 p.m.
it's in Richmond Virginia as Jim just
said have you thought about maybe some
sort of a Star Wars theme to play on may
the 4th be with you that's pretty good
you know probably more people coming to
see Christine Davis didn't seem a ok but
it's going to be a great event and we
hope to raise some money I mean I'm
doing a lot of small and medium sized
events I did an event in the villages
you know which is a community outside of
Orlando last week the average age was
deceased
it was a huge crowd we raised a lot of
money that's fantastic right did you
ever think though isn't it hard to be in
a place where I mean obviously you were
you've had money where all this now you
have to do benefits to raise money for a
lawyers I mean you never saw this
company right well but I'll get it all
back once I'm vindicated now I'm the
best-known political operative on the
face of the planet and I can get on
important shows like oh I don't know
Timmons and that's true and I would like
to also state for the record just
because I think it's important that it
stay on the record that you did at one
point on this very show tell me that in
a very hypothetical way if for whatever
reason related to what we're talking
about or not you were to at any point in
your life end up in jail you would still
call the show so that is that is out
there just so we keep that in mind as we
move forward that is that I'll keep that
commitment okay thank you very very much
Roger one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app
[Music]